[Music]
do you ever get bored of porn no but you
don't ever um of the same the violent
boring in the same way I can get bored
of porn yeah me too sometimes I'll be
like alright i I'm gonna switch to in
the deems level of imagination cuz uh
this is this is getting repetitive I
don't watch it as much as I did when I
first when I was younger because I mean
when you're younger you're a front row
version or you don't have a much
experience with women right so like
obviously the real thing is way better
obviously it is very better but oh the
porn is stationary when you get bored of
it then what do you do not jackoff
yeah you just come watch Netflix like a
real switches special medium switch your
inspiration platform because I've got
I've watched porn for like three hours
before in every hour yeah cuz you're
just like edging the entire time that
long yeah it just goes dude you've been
edging for so long like just [ __ ]
give up now
that means requested a big wheel you
could edge for three hours the reason
you can is because you lost a working
license that you're not thinking right
cuz I could I probably collectively done
three hours in a day edging and I'll
bust [ __ ] do it again bus and then my
dick is raw and it's like dry heaving
and in the next morning I'm like I
rested and it's still just like just
twenty percent recovered and I'm still
[ __ ] busting it still feels a lactic
acid the other day basically I don't do
that anymore cuz I'm I don't know I was
like that was me and my high school days
imagine when it when you're like [ __ ]
seven years old losing 70 yeah cuz this
video this tik-tok video is of this
chick with her neighbor watching porn
too loud and he's like [ __ ] 70 or
something I think we can't hear them
yeah he needed to be loud no he's
watching porn too loud
retro porn can you shut up so it's 25
can you turn off your pot turn off your
porn
I think he's so old he can't hear can
you please turn your pulling off because
those kids that can hear every single
day porn you listening to we can hear
every single day it's really it's really
loud then what is like huh and there's
kids upstairs who can hear it turn out
yeah yeah the suspenders off
you didn't tell he's bad at hearing
already from that he needs to be like
she should like buy him some air pod to
Bart's dad he would watch a Chinese
military parade at full [ __ ] blast I
was like I don't even listen to this
[ __ ] cuz you used to be his roommate
right yeah yeah like what time I mean
all throughout the day - tastes like he
also came here so like there's time
[ __ ] blast in whatever [ __ ] wushu
film or military parade whatever and
I'll come on and I come over to visit
him I already four roommates home oh
yeah at all home
I'm buddy don't you want to turn it down
a little bit cuz it's [ __ ] loud as
[ __ ] but he hasn't although still those
two speakers that are both like three
feet tall they're [ __ ] loud but he
just can't hear so even now like when
I'm talking to him I don't even try to
explain anything anymore cuz it
literally be like hey Dad are you
already stocked up for quarantine he's
like huh like are you stocked up on
quarantine do you go to suit my haha and
I have to say like five times and then I
think even he gets tired of it cuz and
he'll just make up something here but
nah
get a dog he knows you try getting a
hearing aid she has um no he doesn't he
doesn't want him because it'll kill his
game right yeah yeah so he got these
small I can't get no [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] so he got these little ones but I
was like maybe they're wrong and the
thing is too is when they run out of
batteries it doesn't tell you so it
could be he had him on and they were
working good in this slowly just faded
and it doesn't go like do out of
batteries so he just has him in his ear
and there's like no battery yeah my
mom's always complaining about my dad
playing [ __ ] so loud especially if he's
gonna karaoke oh my gosh you ever been
to a Vietnamese household when they're
karaoke yeah you could hear that [ __ ]
from down the street it I didn't even
think that was like by himself and he'll
be carrying as loud as he can possibly
do it when I'm watching porn I'm in my
bed in the farthest corner in my room
that's completely away from everywhere
now so behind me is just a bit away yeah
and then they're all in the other rooms
over there and I won't just you know how
it goes from nothing to one bar one
little dot on the iPhone right that's it
that's already too loud sometimes hey
you know what I heard you're scared of
you in here yeah you know what I hate is
whenever like you're trying to like
watch the beginning part important and
like they don't have like a proper audio
equipment right so you hear the [ __ ]
dude behind the camera is so [ __ ]
loud and then when the girls talking
you can barely [ __ ] here see if I turn
it up for the girl part don't make her
side comes out knowing the guys talking
behind the camera it's all [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] hate proper audio cut
like you're watching like sometimes they
don't like when you start it you don't
have to worry if you're because they
don't just start [ __ ] and they start
screaming right but sometimes it because
they play ads like they do on YouTube
right but the ads everyone knows the
song for the eyes of the play right
that's it huh yeah if I play the whole
tik tok challenge around there yeah like
intro so the tick-tock challenge where
the girlfriend will go up next to the
boyfriend and play the the portal intro
and then see his reaction if he goes
well that sounds familiar what's going
on or if he's like what is that
and it should be like oh you don't know
what it is good job suspend out school
for the talent shows yeah you start
playing the drum beat yeah it's just the
drum beat yeah it's just sighs it's just
like basically almost like the dumb dish
right they play that and they get
suspended cuz even the teachers know but
shouldn't the teachers get arrested what
water I mission it's you just be in
trouble why are they blaming on the kids
the teachers are allowed to watch porn
on their own times and should be allowed
to watch porn like no porn references in
school that's right that's why even a
bigger deal because of that tick tock
thing until all the kids are like yeah
we all know what it is whether or not
they went to pornhub do they really got
a band porn for kids it's not not
because it's inappropriate because I'm
jealous it's not fair that now that I'm
an adult and I can have sex and like all
that stuff it's not fair doing a lot to
have sex when you're younger yeah but I
mean the quality of sex is not the same
and in the you know the porn back then
wasn't the same so you know the girls
weren't watching the kind of porn today
you know what I mean so like so here's a
difference I think the kids are more
sexually liberated today girls just more
like porn stars today like cam girls are
cool today you know where there was more
sexual shame back in a day yeah so
was a horny [ __ ] and I was just
waiting for the world to catch up and
now I feel like we're all on the same
page and I'm like well it took you long
enough time your [ __ ] but I'm
jealous of that my childhood because
they in high school are getting [ __ ]
porn star level sex when I had to wait
till college for that [ __ ] and on top of
that the quality the porn I had is like
I was so desperate I just had to find
something in the porn back then was so
bad yeah like ron jeremy like and some i
never made for whatever and you just oh
man the things that turned me on man i
never listed the ron jeremy thing
especially growing up notes for old guys
that are like ya know what it is yeah
cuz going up i was like he's this like
short
weird-looking dude with a big mustache
why is he the porn icon on he's a big
dick too yeah yeah sure but like you
don't look at everything else - no i
can't even watch his because like he's
so hairy as he's sweating all them
together they just look it's just
distracting i feel bad for the girl I
feel like the porn from back then was a
little more like there's like a bit more
like can I say the word rapey
I don't know it's not a word that would
that's gonna get flagged on YouTube I
don't know but uh extra extra aggressive
well no it's not extra aggressive it's
just like I don't know yeah I don't know
like I got one Christmas song right it's
called baby it's called out there you
don't know ya know like like yes way
slap the girl kiss her well I mean
there's a lot of that going on now oh
you're like but like the guys that are
in the videos or like yeah they're
younger and like the age is like closer
to each other when it's normal all like
the back in a day it was like a huge age
just yeah it was like
forty fifty year old dude with my 18
year olds you know and there's like this
like kind of like that got these young
Indians it's more PETA sh pedo pedo ish
yeah that's the word that's the word now
know cuz now it's like real couples that
are hiding their face and they have
their they're like youtubers they make
their own account on pornhub and they
have their own [ __ ] and it's POV and all
that it's more intimate and real life
yeah and the people look better yeah
because there was the whole porn star
era where the women were like stars
right but then now it's just like
YouTube and everything it's like
everyday people doing porn and it's
hotter in my opinion and then I think
people are even dressing like porn stars
that's true what's that mean that's why
we did a branded high schoolers man [ __ ]
them wait what did that point star
outfit I wanted it's okay guys just
naked when you think about it right the
style today girls are more confident
provocative set their face express
themselves more sexually they're
comfortable with their sexuality and I
always wanted that because I thought
that was dope and I wanted I don't know
and then like it was difficult for me to
communicate sexually with the
girlfriends because like I would talk
about it and they'll be socially Shay
and I feel like weird to be you're wrong
for even wanting that right yeah shame
you so you want that goes to have the
shame that you had the shape the same I
want them to have the shame I want them
it's not fair share in the same yeah but
now yeah I think people are just way
more comfortable with their body with
everything and it's like back then - if
a girl didn't have a perfect body she
wouldn't wear like stuff right like she
wouldn't wear certain clothes like and
girls were way more covered up but now
they don't have to be and feel perfect
to feel sick whether you can I be a lot
of positivity [ __ ] oh god it sounds like
it's like what now people are so
comfortable in their clothes and they
can just not you
fitness clothing when you're not fit
that's crazy
I think that's a good thing that's what
I always wanted
yeah like I always wanted like I'm like
dude you are [ __ ] hot
what are you doing but then if a girl
wasn't perfect and skinny she didn't
feel confident back when we were in high
school or whatever but now I see way
more you guys don't deserve this I see
what you're saying it's like the hotness
is in the confidence of a girl Oh
hundred Brian is that's so much like
what the action look like cuz I was
waiting for the world to get [ __ ]
cuz I'm like I don't know cuz then uh
I've met a few partner so we want to
like all that advanced I was going to
like you like and the people that say
all these youtuber fights right they're
like all their friends are these huge
more than the people that I've been
watching a lot of I see you naked
I seen you yeah so like I've met them
where they even came up like you to some
sounds good score in the I know who you
are yeah and like we're like on the
party bus and like all that stuff and
then they're like I don't know how to be
like oh I know who you are a big fan but
then it's like they're 10 times crazier
especially not because they're supposed
to media people how crazy those like
influencers like that type of influencer
gets but they're like literally they're
like getting naked making out with each
other doing this and be like oh it's
like your dick if you post this oh no
she was too easy
no it's just disgusting I like I like I
like intimate sacred sensual sex yeah
but I wouldn't mind being an observer
there I wouldn't mind I would watch
everything once but not like what you
experience it's like oh this is cool but
I don't think I'd be like yeah I'll show
you if you suck my dick
cuz it turned me off from watching her
videos already yeah no I just think
she's nasty you're a nasty person yeah
dirty
oh yeah well that motional connection i
still watch our videos oh you do oh you
know yeah tell the truth man it's like
it's not as much as before debris it was
funny where I left it off
[Music]